The space shuttle is one of the most iconic spacecraft ever created.
It stands over 184 feet tall, which is as tall as an 18-story building.
In order to lift all of that weight, the space shuttle has some serious horsepower.
Its two solid rocket boosters create 2.8 million pounds of thrust each...
...and eject exhaust up to 600 feet from the nozzle.
But that's not all it has.
It also has three main engines that are each the size of a car,...
...and create over 500,000 pounds of thrust apiece.
Which makes them very thirsty.
Each engine can drain a 3,200-gallon pool in only nine seconds.
In order to fuel these engines, the shuttle has to carry an external fuel tank...
...that has the capacity of 526,000 gallons or 45 large fuel trailers.
That's a lot of fuel.